given the inertia um of wine regulations
and wine laws the only way to begin to
get them repealed or reformed is to
bring them to
light my name is Tom work and for the
last 25 years I've worked in the wine
business as a marketer and as a consumer
advocate for uh for wine consumers for
wine lovers I started the American wine
consumer Coalition with a number of
other people because we noticed that
whenever issues of consumer access to
Wine were debated the Health Community
was consulted producers were consulted
wholesalers were consulted retailers
were consulted law enforcement was
consulted but the consumer was never
consulted right now 40 states allow wine
to be shipped into the consumer but only
14 states allow consumers to have wine
shipped to them from an out ofate
retailer it makes no sense whatsoever
and it it serves only to protect local
retailers and to protect wholesalers
it's rent seeking at its
worst
the industry tends to be broken down
into three constituent Parts you got the
producers the folks who make the
beverage then in the middle you've got
wholesalers and Distributors and they
then sell the product to retailers and
restaurant tours where we buy the wine
from it's that group primarily in the
middle the wholesalers and the
Distributors who have an inordinate
amount of power that's existed and sat
with them going all the way back to
repeal of Prohibition in Most states
it's illegal for a produc producer of
wine to sell directly to a retailer by
law they have to go through the
wholesaler if that weren't the case
producers would have a lot of other
options in terms of getting their wines
to Market but when you have a law in
place that says You must use a
wholesaler that gives the wholesaler all
the power and what's resulted from that
is this tremendous increase in power and
wealth among a small group of
wholesalers who have in large part over
the last 20 to 30 years done as much as
they can to put the brakes on consumer
access to
wine
Pennsylvania is probably the most
restrictive state for wine consumers in
Pennsylvania it's the state that sells
all the wine you don't have any private
retail outlets um there's no direct
shipping into the state of Pennsylvania
so if you're a wine lover in
Pennsylvania and you want to buy one of
these great Napa wines made from a small
producer or a sowa county Pino Noir
chances are you're not going to find it
in a state
store the best of all worlds would be
California for wine consumers in the
first place a winery in California if
they choose to can sell their wine to a
distributor who will then sell it to
retailers and restaurant tours or if
they choose they can sell it directly to
a retailer or a restaurant tour and of
course they can also sell it directly to
the consumer but in addition to that
consumers in
California they can buy from out of
state and have it shipped to them they
can buy from a New York Winery who will
then ship it to them or they could buy
it from a New York retailer who will
then ship it to to them that's the way
it should be a producer should not be
told that they have to go through a
middleman and a consumer shouldn't be
restricted from accessing the wines they
want the US is one of only four
countries in the world with the drinking
age as high as 21 the other three are
Indonesia Mongolia and palao I would
encourage someone to to refrain from
alcohol use until they turn 21 um there
are lots of things that people can do
that don't involve alcohol 18 19 20 year
olds are going to drink there's just no
getting around it so puking you guys on
board oh
[Music]
yeah